- Is it true, speaking of artists,
is it true that Busta Rhymes
is why you became an actor?
- Busta has had a long
influence-
- Look at this picture!
I love that this is your- (both laughing)
- That's your inspiration, I love it.
- So when I was 12 years old,
there was one of the
best shows ever on TV.
On TV was this "Arsenio Hall Show."
- Hoo, hoo, hoo!
- Me and my mom, right!
- Yeah, I'm the same age, I think, yeah.
- We would always sit
on the floor and watch,
'cause we had a floor model TV, right?
- Yeah.
- So we'd sit on the floor
and watch Arsenio Hall.
- Yeah.
- And Leaders of the New
School was on "Arsenio Hall."
- Ah.
- So Bust,
they were performing "Scenario."
Busta comes out to do his verse
and he is on a Dr. Seuss hat.
- [Kelly] Sure.
- And he goes, "Powerful
impact, boom goes the cannon."
And his hat goes-
(tongue trilling)
And literally the entire
audience goes crazy.
Like Arsenio Hall runs off the stage,
the cameras are shaking.
Like, we're in our living
room like, "Holy (censored)!"
And my mom's standing in the back.
It was in, it was...
And I was like, "Mom,
I want to be that guy."
- I love that that's what you said.
- And I was like, I wanna be,
that guy affects change.
I wanna be that guy.
- Yeah.
- And then I met him and I
was like, "You're that guy."
(guest laughing)
- That's awesome.
Mine was Mariah.
Her first performance was "Arsenio."
- Right!
- And I was sitting there
going, "I wanna do that."
- I wanted do that.
- Yeah.
She sang, "Vision of Love"
and I was like, "Whoo!"
- She killed it.
- Yeah.
- She killed it. She a killer.
- I missed Busta's.
I'm gonna Google that tonight.
- Yo, it is the craziest
show you've ever seen.
- I love that, okay.
- Tore up the studio.